The joe rogan experience when I started doing nights or doing yoga when I travel
and I feel better,
I feel a lot better doing that.
That's because all the girls that yoga pants in the class,
it makes you feel better too.
Is that what it,
is she excited?
Maybe I'm misunderstanding the whole thing.
No Yoga.
That was the pig.
I could just go to the yoga pants.
Sure.
Yeah.
You can just go to a strip club and you feel great.
Well,
I started going to strip clubs on the road and I just a I really,
it really picked me,
I'm sure I wrote down in a strip club name.
I played Largo the other night and there's a place across from it.
I don't know what it's called in the phone book,
but the name on the outside of the door is star strip is all the same font and
font size.
Star Strip.
Totally nude live nude girls,
girls,
girls.
The stars chip on La Cienega.
Yeah.
Dude,
I,
I had a bit about that it true story.
Um,
where the girl was dancing and I said,
hey,
do you,
do you like doing this?
She goes,
I don't talk to guys who come here.
And I said,
well,
why?
I mean it's an open door.
I mean like nice people can come through too.
And she goes,
well,
most guys who come here,
they only come here for one reason.
I mean,
why did you come here?
Like she was like shutting me down.
And I said,
cause someone told me there was a place that I could do go where I could see a
strange girl's pussy for a dollar.
Okay.
And that was the joke.
Like I'm the asshole.
I only did it show up where you work.
All right,
I'm a bad person because he worked here,
you know,
different people go to different places,
different reasons to go to strip clubs a lot.
And you know,
it turned me off.
I was in Nashville once,
I saw a commercial on TV for a strip club.
And I was like,
I would like,
that seems fun.
I'll go there.
And,
uh,
and they went and then I gave the guy my id when I walked in and he goes,
Hey Mike Birbiglia I like your comedy.
And I was just like,
I'm never going to a strip called forget.
I've never got back.
Why?
Because they don't want you to know.
You're like the anonymity of it.
I don't want to be,
I don't want anyone to watch me watch someone be nay.
I just,
I'm not,
I can't handle that.
You need a wig in a fake mustache id.
A wig or a fake mustache.
I can you one.
We're in Hollywood.
There's plenty of stores.
Yeah.
I,
that's why I'm here.
I sorry it took so long for me to get to the point,
but uh,
yeah.
Do you have like a cost to microwave?
Cause I really want to go.
The California thing is whenever,
you know someone's come from California because in the first 30 seconds they
tell you something incredibly intimate,
intimate about their life.
Like,
Oh yes,
I used to be addicted to drugs or like I was molested and I'm like,
that's why they're here.
Dog burdened me with this shit.
I don't want to know that.
It's sad,
but that's why they're here.
Yeah.
You know it's weird because this is also the,
obviously people create all over the world,
no doubt about that.
But when you come to like creating things that get attention,
this is like the pub of the universe creating things that get attention.
It's almost all in Hollywood.
It's like a big chunk of it,
whether it's movies,
TV shows,
blah,
blah.
Who needs attention?
People that didn't get enough or people that got too much of the wrong con and
those are the ones that seek out and seek out validation.
So they all come here.
It's so weird.
Mathematical process.
Oh,
he's loved Angelina.
I believe he always left her.
Now the whole blonde bombshell just put fucking billboards of herself and came
famous just for that.
I saw her the other day just picking her nose and eating it and then you posted
something about,
you saw somebody picking your nose and eating it like the day after and I'm
like,
what the fuck?
That's hilarious.
I love that pink corvette around
a wig.
She was a on the PCH,
the Topanga to the pcs on the merge were stopped at the light and I look behind
and I watched this old lady in a wig just dig,
pull out,
I'll whopper and just start chewing.
I mean,
she was openly chill enough mouth open chewing,
and I was like,
wow.
And all I could think of,
of course for the rest of the day it was that she probably came over here in
1955 and she wanted to be a star and she was hot and it just didn't work out.
And now she's wearing a wig on the PCH chewing or burgers in her blue Saturn
with fucking faded out paint.
It was a very weird watch as I thought it was.
I thought she always drove a vet.
Now that's Angelina [inaudible].
Angelina,
I saw some random crazy lady was light blue Saturn.
I do that with people.
I like try to piece together what their story was,
what's,
what's it?
That fucking mind always goes down to drugs and blow jobs.
The story's all there.
Very unoriginal.
They always,
you know,
somewhere along the line someone blew Burt Reynolds.
That's always in my stories.
So Jordan would show up at a place in 2000 women would show up to meet him
there.
7,000 women would get the text message,
Michael Jr.
Oh my God.
Imagine the pussy that has been thrown at Michael Jordan.
It's not even,
you can't even wrap your head around.
You know,
it's like,
it's like locusts
step outside.
Oh
yeah.
He's as multiple suits now for people that are like this,
this is your kid.
And he's actually won suits and he keeps winning.
I'm winning them cause there's,
that's how you know he's so famous.
I think there's probably people that did feel like you did fuck me.
He's like,
I didn't make a kid with you.
Well,
this is also probably,
I'm sure,
but there's also probably people that are like hoping that he'll just pay him x.
Of course.
Just shut up.
Here's some,
here's the 300 grand of shut up.
Yeah.
But you can't just keep doing that.
No.
Especially when you're not making money anymore.
I mean,
how much those Hanes commercials pay?
Oh,
he makes unbelievable money still doing what?
Well,
his shoe brand is the absolute crazy.
Oh,
that's his,
that's his journey.
His Nike owns his brand of Air Jordan,
but he is a huge,
huge benefactor of that brand and he is the number one chew,
uh,
among like that,
you know,
basketball shoes are a huge,
huge multibillion dollar business.
Yeah.
His shoes still outsell the Bron and Kolby,
which is,
and he's been done for years.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
I would say that Michael Jordan's still probably makes him probably like $40
million a year.
God to Aina.
Yeah.
He's,
he's,
as far as business goes,
he has set up,
man.
That's unbelievable.
Wow.
Yeah.
I didn't even think about the sneakers,
but it's,
it,
it is incredible when you hear about a guy who was so awesome that still to this
day,
it's amazing.
His name rings in the hallowed halls.
They do that.
Oh look,
I'm sorry,
that was off by 40 million.
God,
yes.
But how many athletes can say that?
None.
He's number one edible.
They do that.
That,
I think it's like a Q rating where they rank the impact of just athletes and the
top 10 is like always the craziest list of guys who you all,
we all know who they are at tiger woods,
right.
I mean Michael Jordan is number one.
He's been number one for like 25 years and the lowest he ever dipped,
he went to like number two once under tiger woods.
Pissed.
Very pissed.
I bet he was.
Yeah.
Thing is that he is a notorious gambler.
He's actually a really good golf golfer.
Like he has like a real game,
you know.
And he would bet wouldn't,
it wasn't uncommon for him to bet a quarter million on a round of golf.
And he would also,
uh,
they said like,
when he goes to Vegas,
he does,
you know,
Shit like that for fun because he makes 80 million a year.
It's incredible.
What a weird life that guy has.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
And he's getting married.
He got married.
Yeah.
Something Young Hottie too.
She's so hot.
Ooh.
Well Cuban,
I think she's a half Cuban or a Cuban.
Just like fuck it.
I'll just give her a little piece.
Yeah,
give a little piece of this cash.
You think that's,
um,
pretty airtight prenup you'd get when you married Michael Jordan.
Oh,
I imagining it goes through several layers of lawyers looking for,
anyway,
your lawyer sends it back.
They're like,
listen.
Yeah.
Do you like him?
Do you want this to work?
There's no other lawyer this.
Just sign it.
You can't negotiate.
You get 23 and you for life.
That's a good deal.
Right?
And he's just a maniac gambler.
Just gone off with an 80 million a year coming in every year.
And that's why you can't say shit about what was gambling?
I lost $1 million gambling today.
10 years plus he's making like a hundred.
You mean,
think about that.
It's so crazy.
$100 million a year close to it for 10 years.
I mean,
how long does it take?
Does he have a billion?
Do you think it has a billion?
A billion?
Yeah.
I mean,
if you make an 80 million a year,
and he was famous for,
I don't know if it was him or his agent at the time,
but he's famous for being one of the innovators in the,
when he was getting these crazy,
um,
endorsement deals,
he was getting stock as part of his deal.
So like,
he would get millions of dollars to sponsor,
you know,
to be the endorser of Gatorade,
but then insisted on owning stock.
Well,
guess what?
When Michael Jordan started endorsing Gatorade,
stock went up pretty significantly,
and he made many,
many more millions than he would have.
So he's pretty innovative in that sense too.